on February 4th of 2021 the Nevada
County Sheriff's Office received calls
from the residents of Alta Sierra
California about a woman who was walking
down the street with her two kids she
had been knocking on random doors asking
for a ride to the California state lines
the woman claimed she was being followed
by someone and she was right that
woman's name was Sage Crawford and less
than an hour later Sage would lose her
life in an unexpected and awful tragedy
I'm Mr Black and this is the disturbing
truth
originally from the state of New Mexico
Sage Crawford had moved to Cali's Nevada
County sometime around 2019. According
to some sources she relocated to the
region after her husband Isaiah Crawford
passed away in a tragic motorcycle
accident on May 28th of 2017. Isaiah was
just 32 years old when his life was cut
short unexpectedly he left behind a
young daughter his wife sage and loving
relatives all who were devastated by the
loss of their dear loved one but what
makes his passing even more tragic is
that Isaiah's Widow Sage was left to be
a single mother not just to their
daughter but also to the one that was
still in her womb Sage Crawford was
sadly pregnant when Isaiah died
According to some after his death she
changed her name from Deirdre Eloise
Hawkins Crawford to ariela Sage Eloise
Crawford the reason for this remains
unknown to the public as far as I can
tell on the evening of Wednesday
February 3rd Sage contacted some people
and claimed she was being harassed by
law enforcement enforcement she also
expressed concern for the safety of her
two daughters aged four and six this was
said to stem from a possible incident
that occurred at a nearby shelter but I
couldn't find any reports to support or
refute this claim people who had contact
with sage in the days leading up to her
death described her as afraid but not
erratic the Nevada County Sheriff's
Office responded to the aforementioned
calls regarding Sage Crawford and
arrived at the Alta Sierra neighborhood
on Thursday February 4th 2021 at around
1pm a report from a concerned resident
indicated that a young woman who seemed
to be acting rather odd possibly under
the influence of something was walking
on the side of the road with two young
children a short moment later another
call was received by a different
resident from the same area this person
claimed to have interacted with the
woman that woman was obviously Sage
Crawford and the two little kids were
her own daughters the caller explained
to the 9-1-1 dispatcher that she was
worried about sage and her children Sage
wanted a ride to the county line she
also claimed someone was following her
and as I already stated Sage was right
someone was following her the caller
even explained to the dispatcher that
Sage was telling the truth and described
the vehicle that was tailing the scared
mother and her little girls but the
dispatcher quickly explained to the
caller that the car following Sage was
simply the other concerned citizen that
had first called 9-1-1 to report the
mother's odd behavior deputy sheriff
Caleb tutoring Deputy Matthew Harrison
and Deputy Micah arbaugh all arrived at
Miss Crawford's location at around 1 22
pm
as soon as they exited their vehicles
they informed Sage that herself and her
children were not in any danger or
trouble not knowing any information
other than what they'd been told by the
dispatcher there's no way the officers
on the scene were ready for the events
that were about to transpire that day
what you're about to see is police
footage from the day in question I must
warn you it's extremely hard to watch
viewer discretion is advised
I'm not gonna touch your videos but I
need you to put your knife away
she has a knife I'm not gonna hurt your
babies hey I'm not gonna hurt
it happens to me okay everyone in the
whole world listen
what's up babies
okay I'm not saying anything I just want
to help you out they know who you are I
just want to help out
okay
hold up you want back up
just talk to us
talk to us
listen talk to us
don't want to kill you
thank you
tonight
hey back up back up take a breather hey
[Applause]
you're grabbing
don't you lie
Put The Knife Down
with the knife down scared they're not
scared you're good bro I'm good
I need you to drop the knife
hey you are you still connected on the
taser my taser's down there it didn't
take okay she charged me as soon as it
went up okay get your medical bag ready
okay
after the tragic incident a badly
wounded Sage Crawford was taken to the
hospital where sadly she would pass away
due to her injuries the two little girls
now reside with their extended
biological family and the officer that
pulled the trigger was put on
administrative leave it's unclear how
long the leave was in effect for but on
July 17th of 2022 the District
Attorney's Office released an official
statement saying that all of the
officers involved in the tragedy were
found on the right side of the law in
relation to the shooting of sage
Crawford there were no charges filed
against them after the dash cam footage
was released the public reaction was
split in two sides one side screamed
police brutality and mental health
awareness as questions arose in regards
to how police should respond when it
comes to these kinds of calls the other
side praised police for doing what they
had to do in order to protect themselves
in a situation where someone with a
deadly weapon seemed hell-bent on
harming someone with it but no matter
what side you stand on here one thing
should be clear to everyone there were
no winners present the day that Sage
Crawford was gunned down in front of her
kids as she seemingly tried to stab a
police officer it's a harsh and cold
reality but from where I'm sitting that
is the truth of what happened
[Music]
local activist Leah shank founder of
impact a non-profit social justice-led
activist group was interviewed by the
Union newspaper in regard to the tragedy
she demanded Justice for sage Crawford
and her family as she classified the
event as a case of police brutality
shank demanded to know why lethal force
was used to stop Miss Crawford while I
deeply feel for all sides in this
needless tragedy that indeed seems to
involve someone in the middle of a
psychotic episode of some kind I saw the
video in full for myself over and over
and I'm left with little doubt this
appears to be a clear-cut case of
self-defense the officers from the start
of their engagement with sage genuinely
appear to be trying to help her it's not
like they rushed at her with guns drawn
even the tone of their voice was
concerned not aggressive as they told
her she wasn't in any trouble but Sage
was immediately aggressive violent and
unresponsive to Cops pleading for her to
put the weapon down she was belligerent
by its very definition but as soon as
the officer spoke she unsheathed her
knife she also claimed to know what they
did to her baby stating that everyone
knows every single person every single
name don't hurt my babies everyone knows
your faces but what did she mean by that
now it's easy to get pulled into
wondering if her claims hold any weight
were her kids being hurt or trafficked
were the authorities already a danger to
her and her children well I would assume
if Crawford's claims held any Merit then
her kids would have been scared of the
cops but in the video they don't appear
to be at one point one of the little
girls even attempts to defuse the
situation by standing in between her
mother and the authorities before
yelling stop but Sage didn't stop and
while she waved that knife around
carelessly in all directions while her
children were running back and forth
further dilutes the idea of coherent
concerns for their protection I say
coherent concerns because I do believe
Sage was actually in fear for the lives
of her and her children I just don't
believe her reason is rooted in the
realm of logic at one point Crawford
even goes as far as to Dangerously grab
one of the children with the same hand
the knife is in if you ask me that's not
rational thinking I mean it's clear to
me that Sage didn't have any malicious
intent outside of self-defense for her
and her family but the problem is that
it doesn't appear that there was any
genuine need for her to defend herself
she goes on to scream Allahu Akbar
several times which again doesn't seem
to make any sense given the
circumstances Sage was obviously
suffering from some kind of mental
condition no doubt about it and it seems
to me in my opinion that her intent was
not to offend but defend unfortunately
for sage and more importantly her
children officers have a right to defend
themselves as stated previously they
informed her that she was not in any
trouble and told her several times to
put the knife down and talk to them they
even made several attempts to put space
between themselves and her and when she
screamed kill me now it's hard to deny
that Sage Crawford was the aggressor in
this situation and she continued to
escalate to the point of charging at an
officer are shouting I'll effing kill
you while brandishing a dangerous weapon
and when the cop's taser failed to stop
her it seems to me like the police were
left with no choice but to shoot
therefore it's my belief that Sage's
actions regardless of where they stemmed
from caused the tragedy that day it was
like either she was going to die or a
cop was going to be badly injured even
as she lay wounded on the ground she
continued to clutch the knife and act
irrationally shouting don't be scared to
die and Allahu Akbar among other things
it's sad that officers were put in a
position where they were forced to do
that to a mother in front of her small
children it's sad that Sage was in a
state of mind that caused her to
needlessly attack police officers that
were by all accounts there to check on
the welfare of her and her children it's
not like they arrived on the scene that
day hoping to gun down a mom
there were no winners that day of course
this likely all stems from a psychotic
break of some kind but it's not police
brutality the cops made every attempt to
de-escalate and use non-lethal force it
simply didn't work you can see it for
yourself in the video Sage acted quickly
no doubt falsely thinking she was
protecting her family but that does not
negate self-defense not in my book there
were no winners that day but the ones
who lost the most they lost two parents
in the space of a couple years and those
cops also have to live with the fact
that they had to take her life in front
of those kids they'll never be the same
either they'll never stop hearing those
screams in their sleep none of the
people involved were pleased with the
result the only one who doesn't have to
live with this tragedy is the aggressor
Sage Crawford who likely due to mental
health reasons got herself gunned down
in front of her kids while seemingly
trying to take the life of a police
officer how would you feel about Sage if
she killed that cop in front of her kids
survived and was arrested would she be a
monster then or just a mental health
victim it's a fair question we have to
look at all the angles when we aim our
finger guns at someone and shoot the
blame there absolutely were no winners
the day Sage Crawford was killed in the
wake of a more prominent Mental Health
crisis caused by our everyday lives
where we're subject to the loss of
family members stress substance abuse
and many other factors one thing Rings
clear people can break
Sage Crawford was not evil but she was
seemingly in an altered state of mind
that made her think others around her
were so what would have happened if cops
hadn't arrived what if she knocked on a
door and she thought the person that
answered was evil what would she do then
I question the safety of others if Sage
Crawford hadn't been stopped I wish he
had been stopped without the use of
lethal force of course but she ran
through the taser even so I'm not
without compassion for sage as I said
before she wasn't evil or a monster but
this video would be very different if
she had killed someone that day that
fact shouldn't be overlooked when you
contemplate how you should feel about
this situation
some people seek professional help for
their mental health some deal with it
themselves or with the help of someone
close to them others bottle it up and
hope everything will be just fine but
then one day life becomes too much and
all that has been bottled gets shaken to
the point that everything inside erupts
Sage is not the first person to have
gone through the dark side of their own
mind and not made it out alive on July
1st of 2019 officer Charles bidinger and
officer David Harrison were called to
the River Club apartment complex near
Macon Highway in Athens-Clarke County
Georgia the police department had
received multiple calls about a young
man covered in blood who had been acting
erratically with a knife in his hand
possibly hurting himself that young
man's name was Aaron hung upon arrival
both officers immediately began to plead
with Aaron to drop the knife but he
simply refused to listen
oh there he is
Central tender
Put The Knife Down Knight down put the
ninth down
Put The Knife Down put it down
put it down
[Music]
he's not complying to command centuries
coming at us with a knife
down
Knife Down Put The Knife Down sir please
put the Knife Down
we can help you out man we can help you
move with his eyes locked on the cop
Hong continued advancing towards officer
David Harrison both of the officers on
the scene maintained a safe distance and
kept stepping back slowly as they
pleaded with Aaron to drop the knife and
just calmed down they spoke to Aaron in
a firm but non-threatening manner
put it down no no
[Music]
no
no no
however he was clearly distraught and
didn't fear death one of the officers
even showed empathy saying please put
the knife down we can help you please
but Aaron responded by telling them to
go ahead and do it judging by his own
words it seems as though he wanted
someone to pull the trigger that day he
said it himself repeatedly but no one
wanted the awful task and it's again
clear these officers weren't there to
harm him they simply wanted to resolve
the situation peacefully as they
continued to try to persuade him to put
the Knife Down hey leslaco
the officers backed all the way up to
Macon Highway Aaron Hong made the choice
to escalate the situation still armed
with the knife he rushed officer David
Harrison in a full-on attack
shots fired Central shots fired
on your back
[Music]
oh no no no no no no get on the ground
get on the ground
go go
get on the ground man
tell you something
no no no
get on the ground
oh my God
oh God
are you good you're good
you're good
Central just shotgun from those officers
gun we've got shots fired again
[Music]
oh God
hey grab my gun
no no I'm not here man I don't know hey
man take a break
okay
and again we witness the making of a
split-second decision to self-defend
after Harrison yelled out for his
aggressor to drop the knife one last
time the cop was left with no choice but
to pull the trigger he fired seven shots
before Aaron fell to the ground and
dropped the knife now you may think
that's excessive for someone coming at
you with a knife when you've got a gun
but the reality is that within seconds
Aaron Hong was back on his feet again
leaving the knife behind he rushed the
cop one more time and got a hold of him
officer Harrison had no time to grab his
taser as a very bloody Aaron Hong
tackled him from behind and began to
reach for his weapon during this attack
officer bidinger drew his taser gun and
aimed at Aaron but as the situation had
drastically escalated further biting her
had a decision to make let Aaron Hong
grab his partner's gun and see what
happens our aim has Lethal Weapon and
carefully pull the trigger he had just
witnessed his partner fire multiple
shots into Aaron hung and the bullets
that hit the outraged man definitely
caused some damage but surprisingly they
didn't stop him sadly officer biding her
to pull the trigger further deploying
lethal Force to protect his partner
after Aaron was shot four more times he
never got up again luckily officer
Harrison sustained minor injuries that
were treated on the spot Aaron Hong was
pronounced dead at the scene both
officers were put on administrative
leave right after the incident
[Music]
Sunday July 16 2023 Manchester
Connecticut police received a call
regarding a domestic disturbance as
officer Haley Willette was approaching
an apartment in a North Main Street
complex she could hear someone yelling
from inside the residence The Sounds
were coming from a man named Joseph de
Loreto and an unidentified woman when
officer Willette entered the apartment
Joseph was already agitated aggressive
and armed with a knife in his right hand
Haley tried to pacify the situation
verbally but Joseph just cursed her off
when she tried to grab his forearm and
he resisted officer Willette immediately
Drew her taser gun she told Joseph to
calm down otherwise she would have to
tase him
show me
an appointment
[Music]
Joseph told her to shoot him right
before he approached the officer she
deployed her taser but it didn't seem to
affect him at all as a matter of fact on
the contrary it seemed to anger him even
more after the taser failed officer
Willette quickly created some distance
between herself and Joseph by retreating
out of the apartment but he followed her
outside as she pleaded with Joseph to
drop the knife and calm down Haley had
pulled out her handgun and aimed it at
him but that didn't phase him at all
Joseph just kept advancing towards the
officer as Joseph closed the distance
between himself and Haley she fired
several shots
[Applause]
that's fine multiple shots fired
as one of the bullets penetrated his
left thigh he fell to the ground finally
she was able to take the knife out of
his hand and handcuff him Joseph was
taken to the hospital and later arrested
he was lucky to survive but he was
charged with second-degree threatening
first-degree criminal attempt to commit
assault and assault of public safety
personnel officer Haley will let was put
on administrative leave
on April 24th of 2023 patrolling officer
Christopher Hamel responded to a 9-1-1
call from a Woodland Avenue home on the
Lawrence Harbor section of Old Bridge
New Jersey according to Luis Mendez his
son 26 year old Luke Mendez lived in the
apartment with his mother grandmother
and aunt turns out police visits were a
frequent recurrence in this household on
that day officer Hamill was responding
to a domestic disturbance between Luke
and one of the female residents over the
placement of a surveillance camera in
the apartment what's going on
um
gotcha so now she's up and down trying
to threatened him with the cops gotcha I
don't know if that's legal that she
could do that it is legal it's our house
whose house is it using him
okay well no you're nobody in the end
everybody everybody lives together so
you know if you want to have a camera
she wants to have a camera she legally
lives here right am I wrong with that if
she legally does live here yeah so if
she wants to put a camera up just as
much as you can she can I can't tell her
if she can't I can't tell her she should
tell you absolutely common courage there
should occur when officer Hamill arrived
he was greeted by three women in the
living room Luke was upstairs in his
room at this time after a quick
discussion in the living room Hamill
went to talk with Luke himself in order
to broker some peace between the parties
involved in the disturbance has the
officer reached the stairs that led to
Luke's room Luke appeared at the top of
him gripping a long bladed knife
look
hello hey how you doing officer Hamill
hey what's going on buddy can I just
talk to you for a minute
yeah I just told you
can I come up and talk to you that way
we have privacy
yeah why do you have a knife in your
head
all right well you got to put the knife
down all right well you got to put the
knives down there yep relax relax relax
relax and Put The Knife Down
headquarters one and gum point knife and
then put the knife down on the floor and
get on the ground Put The Knife Down On
The Ground Put the gun down put the
knife down now
put it down officer Hamill reached for
his firearm and aimed it at Luke while
trying to de-escalate the situation
verbally he tried pleading with Luke
telling him that no one was at fault in
this situation and it wasn't too late to
fix it the cop wanted Luke to relax and
talk things through in order to reach
peaceful resolution but no matter how
many times he was asked the young man
refused to drop the knife just like in
the other cases we've talked about you
can clearly see this officer didn't want
to hurt anyone he simply wanted to
resolve the issue he was faced with come
on buddy talk to me he's on the ways
around as you're upset at them in a
living Arrangement I've spoke to you
before I know you're a nice person
it's a nice person
Come on talk to me
you didn't do anything wrong you're not
in any trouble right now all right
you're not in any trouble right now
don't tell you something to put the
Knife Down stay right there
she can leave and we can leave too we
can all leave together
again this is all workable still a
little workable
we're still all workable
come on
we're good we're still good
we're still good look talk to me come on
everybody out of the house
talk to me come on we're still good
we're still good
you want privacy you're entitled to it
Luke come on buddy talk to me
take a deep breath take a deep breath
that's good take a deep breath look good
we're still good Luke
you're entitled to your privacy and I
want to give that to you I want to help
you
talk to me
Come on talk to me
why are you you're upset about you're
upset about the camera right
she's not allowed to have the camera
roll to your stomach
41 year that's not hard
I can't get his hand all right I got
tonight
sadly de-escalation tactics proved
fruitless a woman can be heard in the
background saying Luke she's leaving for
good but this seemed to heighten his
agitation even further he began to ask
the officer to leave the house several
times but of course Hamill couldn't do
that until he had defused the situation
then suddenly out of nowhere Luke rushed
down the stairs still armed with the
knife yelling out move the cop had to
defensively react to the best of his
ability with Luke only three steps away
from him Hamill opened fire pulling the
trigger three times after the shots rang
out Luke fell to the bottom of the
stairs crawled up and still refused to
let go of the knife but the officer
managed to pull it out of his hands a
short time after the incident Luke
Mendez was taken to a local hospital
where at 4 47 pm he was pronounced dead
[Music]
and yet again the same question arises
who was at fault the officer or Luke was
Luke even trying to hurt the officer or
the lady with whom he had the argument
who knows one thing we do know is that
on that day there were no winners
another person had been lost to the
Judgment of a clouded mind an
investigation was open to decide if the
officer's actions were lawful
[Music]
in all fairness police training should
include a bigger emphasis on mental
health issues and how to act accordingly
in such situations it would be great to
use more pacifying methods of
de-escalation to resolve tensions but
unfortunately we don't have net guns to
shoot at people like they do in
Spider-Man and Batman and sometimes even
those who are well educated on mental
health issues are left powerless when
faced with psychotic breaks mind states
of excited delirium or substance-induced
psychosis obviously these cases are
tragic for everyone involved on both
sides of the line and Sage Crawford's
case her little girls who had already
been subjected to Major trauma by losing
their father were forced to witness a
devastating situation which I have no
doubt has left scars that will never
fully heal Aaron Hong's family and
friends will never have the answers they
seek and Luke's grandmother took the
incident so bad that she herself had to
be hospitalized thank God they treated
her accordingly and she returned home
safe but none of these people will ever
get over the loss of a loved one in all
of these cases in my opinion the police
officers found themselves in immediate
danger they had to risk their own safety
to protect themselves and others that is
what's expected of them it's their Duty
on a daily basis but in doing so they
too were faced with moral dilemmas and
consequences for their own actions as
well as actions of Those whom they are
faced with on any given day I don't
believe these cases display police
brutality and that's not to say that
brutality doesn't exist it does and
someone in law enforcement can most
certainly dish out unjust brutality just
as a teacher preacher and man or woman
of any skin color can but the cops we
saw in the footage featured in this
video were not brutal they were simply
stuck between a rock and a hard place
forced to make a decision no one wanted
to make it's easy to get caught up in
our feelings when we see someone gunned
down but while tragic that doesn't
always mean its brutality or
cold-blooded murder when we cry
brutality and it doesn't fit the
scenario we're effectively crying woof
when there isn't one and when we do that
we minimize real brutality when it
happens you may argue why can't they
just shoot them in the leg well the
simple answer is life is not a 90s Mel
Gibson movie aggressors tend to close
the safe distance between you and them
pretty quickly there are only a few
seconds between your life or theirs
effectively aiming at a leg or an arm
isn't as easy as you think and like
tasers it doesn't always do the job in
2015 Reverend Jarrett malpan LED civil
rights protests shoulder to shoulder
with black lives matter in Arizona after
authorities gunned down a man in Phoenix
he was very outspoken against police
until they invited him to come along and
take their use of training course where
he would be put in real life scenarios
and would have to decide whether or
whether or not to fire his weapon
he accepted an invitation to look at
things from the other side three
scenarios where you have to decide to
shoot or not shoot your gun what kind of
car do you drive this is my car man
the officer is shot dude what's going on
today gentlemen what do you want What's
Happening Here what's wrong with backup
huh
because he was within that zone you know
I felt there was a an imminent threat I
didn't necessarily see him armed but he
he came clearly to do some harm to uh to
the officer to my person because I don't
know what you have under there everybody
look at this guy what are you doing no
shots fired but the suspect did have a
hidden knife in his waistband it's hard
to make that call it's a
it shakes you up I went through the
scenarios too without seeing what Maupin
did no I need to talk to you come on
come on out over here
do you get on the ground get on the
ground first get back
I didn't understand how important uh
compliance was but but after going
through this yeah my attitude has has
changed this is all unfolding in in 10
to 15 seconds people need to comply with
the with the orders of Law Enforcement
Officers for their own sake
as you can see both Jarrett malpan and
the Fox 10 reporter who participated in
the training exercise both learned
valuable lessons about what law
enforcement officers face on a
day-to-day basis we can push for mental
health awareness and we can have civil
conversations about police reform But
ultimately self-defense is self-defense
if you ever find yourself in this
situation and when you charge at anyone
with a weapon they have the right to
defend themself and that might cost you
your life
this is not brutality it's just the
brutal unfortunate and disturbing truth
there are no winners on days like these